even like somebody like Ty is like when
we started like linking up you know the
first thing I was like yo like let's
Skate let's you like pull up and skate
you know what I mean and so like we just
like kind of built our friendship
through that you know with music not
even being like anything you know and so
just like having that friendship based
off that you know I mean him being in my
world and me being able to be a part of
his world like the constructive
criticism and just the friendship in
general it's just like inspiring to me
and it helps me you know I mean just
like grow and push myself and you know I
tell all the homies that's a part of my
friend group and you know new people I
meet I'm like yo like if like when I
send you music like bro like tell me
like if it sucks honest feedback is like
bro I love it like I it's make me great
let's do some honest feedback of your
music right now
let's do it what song do you want me to
listen to uh I mean the new one I just
dropped better position just came out
with a music video That's the newest one
this is live feedback and I'm gonna be
honest with you yeah you know I love it
all right it came out five days ago yeah
where'd you shoot this at uh Arizona all
of it looks like Arizona this looks like
an Arizona Mountain throw that [ __ ] on
the big TV let's do big TV
so
yeah you just yeah I could I could do it
I'm pretty good with that remote
all right we're gonna do some honest
feedback
as DJ head would like to call it yeah DJ
hey sit out DJ
all right this is gonna be good I'm
excited I'm not gonna lie dude I heard
you were a skater and you're from
Arizona and I was like I'm in let's go
appreciate it Arizona love I'm gonna be
honest if anybody's from Arizona is
doing [ __ ] they have a uh open chair
here always appreciate it biased
hey Z uh all right DeSean Jordan
here it is let's see
which mountain is this
that was some Mountain they found in
like
Scottsdale area the homie just kind of
like like location scout and stuff the
homies who like film the video
[Music]
sick car I like the car so far we're
good the music hasn't started yet
is it okay
you've been abducted yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good day today
[Music]
decisions
[Music]
I like the video
I like this I mean it's a good record
thank you
it's like gives me some like uh you know
like kind of like some like uh cardi you
know uh you know some young some young
boy [ __ ] for sure yeah yeah it's not bad
you know what the person to ask would be
Cyrus Flores over there because all he
does is listen to sofego and you eat
[Laughter]
appreciate it it was solid appreciate it
yeah that was I would tell you this it's
better than 99 of the [ __ ] coming out of
Arizona
appreciate it appreciate it yeah thank
you impressed that video was super
though who did the video uh overcast are
they from amazing yeah they got that
channel
um with the umbrella yeah with the
umbrella yeah yeah so like yeah we just
dropped that one we got like I mean I
don't know we probably like probably got
like over like a hundreds like songs I
literally like to try to record every
day but like this was probably the last
one I dropped was like a a more Anthem
turn up and this was probably like the
last Anthem turn that we're gonna do and
then like the next step I'm coming out
is like r b like feel good music because
like that's kind of weird in my pocket
because I really like be singing and
stuff but I'm gonna like slow it down
and go back to like dance hall Vibes and
stuff because I like that type of music
I like making along with this but I
really just like I said like I make it
and like I'll send it like Thai or like
the homies and get the feedback my Bros
in the studio you know what I mean Pat
like it's about like all the engineers
there and then we just kind of like
based the rollout plan off that it's
like I really like you know I mean I
really like being there locked in just
trying to make sure I'm making the best
music you know I mean like right like
you're writing everything are you
punching in uh like I'll go in the
studio put the beat on punch in probably
like six different reps so like
different Melodies and figure out which
one we're gonna go with then just like
go from there but like yeah I love music
and that's my whole goal is just to like
you know like I know like I said I know
it's the crossover is always hard it's
like oh skater oddly trying to be but
like I'm willing to put in the work you
know I mean it just it's definitely hard
man because people are already gonna
just have I wouldn't even tell anybody
you're a skater like if you meet him
through music just tell them your music
and then if they happen to find out
you're a [ __ ] huge skater like and
that's kind of how we like do it we just
spend it like I show the music the music
I make it separate and if people like
people come in off the music and then
find out our skating that's good then
skating vice versa so you know just
really just trying to like make sure to
go out the most natural way and just
like you know doing a tattoo do it at a
point to where it's like undeniable you
know like it's like you're gonna feel
the passion through like the work you
know what I mean and understand that
like you know how how we're dropping the
quality of things is like I'm not just
like trying to that was better than you
eat thank you I'll tell you that
you're the one who put me on to eat
you're like yo this dude's fire this
dude's fire bro you should interview him
and I dm'd him I was like yo I I yeah of
course he didn't reply too busy [ __ ]
being Yeet you know but that's better
than you eat thank you appreciate it Hey
listen I think also think happened to be
on the island by myself where I think
Playboy cardi makes some of the worst
music I've ever heard in my life better
than Playboy cardi ladies and gentlemen
at least better than a whole lot of red
that's for [ __ ] sure before you say